so do this definite integral you noticed
that you've really got a do a arm you've
got to do a substitution obviously but
it's and this is what's hard about
extension to I think you've got so many
different things that you could do to
this that it's kind of your support for
choice where is it back in the days when
you know if you were a teen this didn't
like little anything one thing I can do
this and that's why you have very
limited range of questions you can see
right away and this this is what will
happen in the exam if you try out
something right like I think your idea
was this okay and then you see where it
goes right it quite quickly in this case
it deteriorates you don't get very far
it doesn't do any nice cancelling when
you do this right and then you're like
okay where can I see that
and the answer is well friend in many
places and you still have to deal with
that square root okay
so that's a big red flashing sign when
you have a square root involved like
this okay especially when there's a
square or 1 plus a square underneath it
that's your big signal that it must be
either trig or inverse tree right in
this case it's going to be free we'll
use an identity okay so the question
then becomes who what should I use that
might help me here right now you notice
it's 1 plus X square so you can meet
immediately sort of rule out x equals
cos theta and x equals sine theta
because they're not you're not going to
get anything helpful underneath there
okay
so therefore if you I'm gonna get cos or
sign what might be a good alternative
instead yeah okay so you can instead of
these examples Trenton right now by the
way 10 is not the only option you can
also do 1 plus ya you can substitute it
for say x squared and it would still
give you something else right so you've
got different options here but this
turns out to be a useful way to go about
it
okay so the whole point is how do you
how do you pick out among all the
different options and this is you look
at what you've got there so now let's
try it if that's X
one minus X square that are you like
sign yeah that's exactly right and
they're they're easy ones that I think
for us we're better recognizing this
because we're familiar with using
science getting close squid yeah
anyhow this you can see it doesn't look
like it's gonna be hugely more useful
but it is right because you get a sec
squared with it
right so that means that this is going
to be replaced with a sec squared D
theta that looks like it's going to make
things worse but that's gonna interact
with this x squared at the front at n
square and things are going to neaten up
a little bit before we move on to that
and do the whole substitution we need
our boundaries right so you've got let's
do x equals 3 so tan inverse of root 3
it's pilot 3 and if x equals 1 then
that's an easy one tan inverse of 1 is
powerful okay good so we have all the
pieces we can do all in one hit so now
that okay let's give this a go show me
so we go from PI over 4 to PI on the 3
okay what like a left I've got a sec
squared feet up on the top and the
defeat up over there then you've got a
tan squared and square root of 1 plus
okay right so now you can see what must
head squared is SEC squared so this this
whole thing once your body at the square
root will just be sick right
so that would cancel with one of these
so we were left okay you look at this
and you think okay what can I do with
this whenever it's not that clear and to
me that's not that clear you always just
boil it down to your basic signs and
Kazem you see what you can pull out of
that so being that this is not it's not
yet really nicely integral so that's why
I'm going to go a bit further so what
have I got here
that's going to be so I've got one over
that'll become sine squared on cos
squared and then I'm going to have a cos
from that okay so that cancels with one
of these so now what have I got here hmm
I've got three looks like that cos will
come back up the top on sine squared now
at this point you have to look and stare
hard and think what can I do with this
okay are there any of these kinds of
identities that we can pull out to make
things better the answer is not really
the other thing you can really do
anything here with let's make that a 1
plus cot 1 minus cos squared but that
doesn't help you does it
ok so you think okay I've kind of boiled
down as far as I can go so what trig
things do I know how to integrate
because there aren't that many right so
4 is this I know the integral of sine I
know the integral of cos I know the
integral of tan will be a log function
okay one of the other trig functions
that we know how to integrate now in
reality you have a standard you'll see
in front of you ok you don't have one
well you might have one printed out
actually
okay so you might see on there for
instance that you've got you know SEC
ten right what does SEC 10 integrated -
yeah oh I left out all of the
coefficients it's basically just SEC
like plus C okay now I use this I I
don't know why but I find this easier to
remember that its companion its other
reciprocal which is instead of sec you
use cossack and instead of tan you use
client okay so I use this as my way of
remembering this which is negative cosec
this one comes up no I don't think so
which is why I kind of use this as my
bridge to get to there I
I feel like this comes up more often
right or maybe it's because I'm so used
to integrating tan and I know that goes
to say squared so this kind of fits into
my hand a little more and then I used
that pattern to think about well okay
the other reciprocal is this one the
other reciprocal is this one and
whenever you look to the other one when
you think of like sine goes too close
cause goes the negative sign that's how
I remembered that it's a bit finicky but
I mean your alternative is you just you
just wrote memorize that option okay
it's an extension to 1 which is why they
go for the more obscure options there
and you can see you can see this right
here right see there's a closed over
sign and a 1 over sine and that's
Cosette Claud okay so now I can buy this
as
I'll just write the integral one more
time hi I'm four five three this is
cosec theta can't Athena
defeat oh okay which just integrates
into negative cosec theta with those
particular boundaries so I went and you
can you can do the own evaluation but
but that's where it goes okay so there's
a couple of twists and turns in there
it's a bit mean for such a very question
but I mean that's what makes it that's
what sets it apart as an extension to
integral number one you've got to pick
out a good substitution but even after
you've done that you're not out of the
woods you've got to do enough monkey
around with this and just one more thing
obviously I kind of just went through it
and deduced things but if you know these
really well right you can already start
to think okay which one of these I'm
gonna start to move toward so that
you're not like sort of aimlessly
thinking okay I don't know